when i think of the most dominant
individual seasons of the past decade
uh i hate to have recency bias but
i'm gonna go with patrick mahomes from
2018 as my first pick and i know there's
a lot of good ones out there but patrick
mahomes last year was more than just a
good quarterback he was that was a force
of nature i mean that was greatness what
we saw and to me for a guy that came in
as his first year as a starter to do the
things he did and really we had never
seen anybody other than dan marino ever
do something like that ever before 50
touchdown passes the fate of the team
and how good they were all just relied
on his talents and ability to make big
plays and all the you know clutch
moments at the end of the games whether
it's throwing lefty against the broncos
on monday night football or fourth and
ninth against the ravens in 2018 the
no-look passes he took the league by
storm and is the biggest superstar in
our sport now
uh
mike i'm gonna go with lamar jackson
2019 yeah because who leads who leads
the nfl in touchdown passes and finishes
in the top 10 in rushing and that's
probably what lamar jackson is going to
do he's had the best running season
uh a quarterback has ever had and he's
got a good shot to throw more touchdown
passes than anybody has ever had that
plus the fact
that as great as mahomes was last year i
thought
no one could outshine patrick mahomes
and i'm not saying lamar jackson has
outshone patrick mahomes but what i am
saying is he's been every bit yeah as
sensational in 2019 definitely as
patrick mahomes was in 2018. agreed with
that and that's that's what's so amazing
about jackson because what we saw my
homes do last year so revolutionized the
position
that i just assumed it would be another
generation before somebody else
revolutionized it again
and it's revolutionized a different way
the next year i mean my home said to me
i was asking about lamar jackson on
sunday he said he's doing things we've
never seen a quarterback do before it's
like yeah so are you and they both are
doing it in different ways and and it's
happening in back to back years and it
really is remarkable all right i'm going
back to 2013
uh for a guy who we thought may have
been completely done he had four neck
surgeries the colts cut him loose he had
the the nerve issue in the triceps was
he ever going to be the same again in
2013 peyton manning had the best
quarterback season as a passer that
anyone's ever had with a record
5477 passing yards and a record 55
touchdown passes both stand today even
with everything patrick mahomes did last
year he was still five touchdown passes
short of what peyton manning did in 2013
so that's my pick uh most dominant
individual performance of the past
decade peyton manning
2013 six years ago feels like it was
yesterday yeah no it is crazy and i i
mean i agreed all these were on our on
my list and of course that year was i
mean that was special you know for you
know with the denver broncos yeah we're
not sure what he is and that was really
one of the best offenses we've ever seen
in the history of the nfl they were
unstoppable and manning was uh
unbelievable that year you know these
are like fine wines like like you know
my first round pick it was like mahomes
the the 2018 bottle
it is it was you know
explosive this one is tom brady 2016
and we named it revenge okay it was the
revenge year i don't give a damn tom
brady didn't win an mvp this year didn't
win anything special oh but you know
what he did he served a four-game
suspension for deflategate then came
back with vengeance all right and then
threw 28 touchdown passes two
interceptions and within that year of
course brought his team back to win a
super bowl where they were down 28-3 and
oh yeah that 28-3 comeback not only made
him an mvp of the super bowl but made
him the first quarterback to have five
super bowls ever him and belichick
together that way to me yes there's no
accolades of brady and mvps that year
but that was still one of the most
special revenge tours we have ever seen
in nfl history and brady ultimately got
the last laugh so i had to go with that
one
that's a good one you know that's a
great weird one for you
that is a good go ahead that's a very
good one but i got a weird one for you
and that is 2015 joe thomas left tackle
cleveland browns he played 1107 snaps
for the cleveland browns that year which
is every offensive snap they had that
year
in that 1107 snaps he got his
quarterback hit three
times three times out of 1107 snaps on a
bad team and that year he had the best
run blocking grade in the last five
seasons as graded by pro football focus
and so to me
that was the best year an offensive
lineman had in this decade and i'm
making him my second pick
all right my second pick goes back to
2012 and that was a year that it
appeared that peyton manning was going
to be the mvp he was wire to wire great
for the broncos in his first year back
from that next surgery his first year
with denver and then along came adrian
peterson who had torn an acl christmas
eve 2011. and there were all the
questions about is he going to be able
to go will he be ready for week one
surely he won't be ready for week one
and you know he was a little rusty to
start the season and he had some scar
tissue and you know he had he had a
solid outing at first against the
jaguars to start 2012 and then it just
kind of gradually but
definitely
took off and before you knew it he was
racking up 150 175 yards a game he went
from 84 that first week by the end of
the season it was 150 123 182 171 he had
210 he had 212 and he had 199 in week 17
against the packers to give him 2097 to
just put him within six or seven yards
of eric dickerson's single season record
he won the nfl mvp award that year and
again it all happened within a calendar
year after tearing an acl we hear all
the time oh when you tear an acl it
takes you two years to be back to normal
he had screwed up everyone's
expectations post acl tear what he did
in 2012 and it's a shame he didn't set
the single season record i'm not sure
anyone's ever beaten dickerson's record
peterson's had the best chance and he
did it with a new acl yeah that i mean
that was unbelievable i mean come on i
mean who was expecting that i mean i
think we all thought like oh it's going
to be kind of over for adrian peterson
he'll never be the same and then he came
out i can still remember what was that a
week one game in cleveland where we were
like whoa okay apparently he didn't get
the memo that you're not supposed to be
as good after an acl i can still
remember that run where he like
stiff-armed like seven people and ran
down the sideline for a touchdown um all
right i'm going way back to uh 2011. you
know i can't go with the
all-decade player draft and in my
opinion not pick the best player of the
decade and that's aaron rodgers uh to me
yeah you know it and 2011 was maybe his
finest performance they were 15-1 as a
football team he actually only played in
15 games that year didn't even play 16
games but of course was the mvp had a
rate quarterback rating of over 122 but
45 touchdowns six interceptions ran for
three touchdowns was as dominant and i
think that was as good as a season i had
ever seen a quarterback play and i can
just remember because it was my first
year out of football and i watched a lot
of film and you know i'm ron jaworski
and did all those things here's the
amazing thing about it guys
he did this with a guy at left tackle in
marshall newhouse who's been on eight
different teams and it was his left
tackle all year and we saw tom brady in
just total disarray with marshall
newhouse's left tackle the last few
weeks he did it all year with having to
drop back and look over his left
shoulder and usually make a guy miss and
then throw a missile down the field uh
to me i just thought that was one of the
the greater individual performances i
saw this decade
all right so my last pick here is going
to be
the 2012 season of jj watt
and when you look at this 2012 season of
jj watt what you see
is one of the most incredible years a
defensive lineman has ever had and i
include reggie white bruce smith all of
the great ones can you imagine having
119
total quarterback disruptions that's
quarterback sacks hits batted uh batted
passes significant pressures eight times
a game you are screwing up the opposing
quarterback who's ever done that before
and jj watt was on his way to winning
the defensive player of the year three
times in four years and having an
incredible run imagine
a guy who everybody is double blocking
having
119
patent quarterback disruptions in a
season so jj watt is my third choice in
2012. all right our draft so far most
dominant individual seasons of the last
10 years sims has patrol homes 2018 tom
brady 2016 aaron rodgers 2011 peter king
with lamar jackson 2019 joe thomas 2015
jj watt 2012. i've got peyton manning
2013 adrian peterson 2012 and let's go
ahead and finish with another one from
2012 it was a fine year for nfl talent
it was a fine year for dominance calvin
johnson
1964 receiving yards a record that still
stands and i remember in the offseason
tomorrow cooper was on with this and he
said his goal was 2 000 receiving yards
this year it's like you're aware
nobody's ever done that right yeah
that's okay well nobody's ever done it
and the closest who's ever come to it is
calvin johnson it's a shame he retired
when he did it felt like he still had
gas in the tank but he was banged up he
was a dominant force and it's also a
shame that uh the lions just never did
think about the guys the lions had how
do you not do more with matthew stafford
and dominican sue and calvin johnson
yeah but uh johnson had a great year in
2012 so that finishes it up well they're
the only three guys they had that was
the problem that's the problem yeah yeah
if it was three on three football they'd
have been in great shape exactly they
just it was just it always came down to
them those three having to make a play
and that's just not gonna get it done in
the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports